au tuyau de saint-maurice tournage de
compartiment tueurs un film réalisé par
costa gavras un jeune réalisateur
d'origine grecque
yves montand simone signoret catherine
allégret pierre mondy jacques perrin
sont au nombre des comédiens qui
interprètent ce film compartiment tueurs
retrace l'histoire d'un crime commis
dans un train et de l' enquête effectuée
par la police enquête que manif montant
de eur 156 deuxième georgette été
l'enfant prodigue de la femme à 18 ans
les monts capable pas bien sûr ne
voulait plus la voir
je me suis marié et nous sommes montés à
paris depuis son divorce nous n'avions
plus beaucoup avez vous une idée de la
personne qui a pu faire seul devant le
corps c'est cette yakuza signé
aujourd'hui simone signoret et le
montant c'est la deuxième fois que vous
tournez on s'ennuie pas comment se fait
il qu'on faisait super vus ensemble dans
les films par faudrait beaucoup de temps
pour par exemple on pourrait pas jouer
une histoire et on se rencontreraient
pour faire une histoire beaucoup plus
personne ne croirait qu'on cette
rencontre
du film on va partir ensemble
là c'est très différent parce que moi je
joue à tout ces courts que
on n'a aucun rapport de ma femme dans
l'histoire
quel est votre rôle dans ce film du
porte un titre c'est effrayant
compartiment tueurs jeune dame ne
méprise pas très triste et vos livres
montant rôle au moi je suis un
inspecteur mais un inspecteur de jehro
pris l'accent du midi pour faire ce rôle
et je viens interrogé ma femme parce que
je la soupçonne d'avoir quand même de
participer à l' équipe apte à sa demande
a requis le vois ma femme le suit on
avait compris qu'ils fassent ou de fou
d'avoir participé au meurtre
c'est pour lui dans ce compartiment dans
ce fameux compartiments mais venaient de
passage dans ce film il ya également un
organe est fort physiquement on est prêt
selon et 15 mai oui mais également votre
fille catherine allégret oui catherine
lavoie l'ajustement de l ajustement
maison plan elle arrive et bonjour de
catherine bonjour monsieur petit
difficile de tourner dans le même film
que ses parents c'est à dire où ses
parents chose ça je crois que je serai
malade surtout pour le premier rôle
important je crois que je pourrais vous
ne pensez pas au contraire qu'il
pourrait vous aider qu'ils pourraient
les conseils mais par rapport à moi-même
la façon je me sentirai pas bien il n'y
a pas de problème et jal en ce moment je
suis très mal à l'avouer mais qu'elle
soit plus la niaque et soit partie
ils ont été très loin je crois quel est
votre rôle dans ce film mais ça vous
raconter l'histoire
je m'appelle bambi g18
ennemi 19 ans et je viens travailler
apparu pour la première fois deux mecs
se passe plein de choses ensuite que je
vous dirai pas bio